president trump who has 30 days left in
his term met with lawmakers yesterday
about contesting the electoral college
vote
that he lost he's also pushing attorney
general bill barr to have a special
counsel investigate the election
and take over the tax investigation of
hunter biden
as paula reed reports the man who
supported the president for so long
is firmly saying no
if i thought a special counsel at this
stage was the right tool
and was appropriate i would do i would
name one but i haven't and i'm not going
to
attorney general william barr torpedoed
several of president trump's political
priorities monday
saying there is no need to investigate
the president's claims of election fraud
or name a special counsel to investigate
president-elect joe biden's son hunter
i think to the extent that there's an
investigation i think that it's being
handled responsibly and professionally
currently within the the department i
appreciate everybody
there i've spoken on a call monday with
a young conservatives conference
president trump seemingly shot back at
barr's thoughts on the election
we need backing from like the justice
department and other people have to
finally step
up the president also met monday with
his personal attorney rudy giuliani and
several members of congress chief of
staff mark meadows described the meeting
as an effort to fight back against
mounting evidence of voter fraud
but didn't elaborate on any evidence or
examples
sources tell cbs news the group
discussed challenging the electoral
college vote in january
but a top republican senator immediately
shot down the idea
vice president-elect kamala harris said
republicans privately believe the
election has been decided
i have to believe that at some point
reality will set in
and that everyone will understand
that we need to govern president-elect
biden is expected to speak later today
in delaware
we're still waiting to hear his pick for
attorney general
tomorrow president trump heads to his
resort in palm beach florida
where he is expected to spend christmas
at new year's
i'll read for us at the white house
thank you